let's watch this I might cut it out
because somebody texted it to me even
though they know they're not supposed to
text a place of honor in our hearts for
you Lord we know that we can't receive
anything from anyone until we have honor
in our hearts for them first of all I
don't know what this
is it's Rick penino who I don't know who
that is but obviously he's also the lead
singer of Smashmouth because that's what
he looks like and he couldn't look more
like the guy from [__] flavor town or
whatever it
is first worst audio recording of all
time so just like Moses
yeah as a sign of
Honor as a sign that you are removing
the things that separate you from the
holy place I just invite you to kick off
your shoes right now kick off your shoes
okay come on everybody all over this
place I don't care how young you are I
don't care how old you are kick your
shoes off in this why does that have to
do with age that's so funny he's just
using like buzz catch phrases I don't
care how young you are or how old you
are kick off your shoes not not hard no
matter what age you
are I don't care how young you are or
how it doesn't matter if you're black
white asian kick your shoes
off male or female alike these guys say
so many words because their their [__]
is such [__] these [__] preachers
is such [__] that they have to fill
so much space that they just start doing
these Buzz catchphrases which is
basically what this podcast does
too
and while you're down there grab a
couple
socks it's
insecure Wow Come on didn't even finish
the word on everybody going to grab
something to
spin this guy's on complete acid is this
a
preacher this guy is on Adam you guys
ready this guy literally put a sheet of
acid in his [__]
like tucked it in his socks and then it
rained and now he just thinks he's
orange juice go ahead
guys come on put those things up spin
your shoes sock keys I don't
care you don't
care everybody you're not spinning
anything come on grab
something
everybody sense secure how he laughs
yeah wow sense secure the
[Music]
yeah let's sing
this oh we're done we done dude you spin
me right round Jesus right round just
didn't
even
try you you spin me right round Jesus
right round dude didn't even
try didn't add the word in the right
place malfunctioning religious bot dude
malfunctioning religious bot you spin me
right round Jesus right around religion
dude I am a preacher You Spin Me Right
Around Jesus ride
round dude so
[__] we'll create him to look like
one of
them we will create him he will have
spiky hair and shave the sides of his
hair we will put him in something that
you can definitely buy at Pack
Sun and we will give him cool
songs but add Jesus you spin me right
round Jesus right
around you lift me Jesus
up You Raise Me Jesus
up Jesus just wants to have
fun oh Jesus just wants to have that's
all really Jesus
wants is some
Jesus dude this guy's a
[__] more I mean what's H why are
they swinging their socks dude just
thinks he's orange juice had a sheet of
plastic in his socks and it
rained
taking so many Liberties
dude wow this
guy dude this is
unbelievable you spin me right round
Jesus right
round dude this is unreal
dude sing it oh he now he's just sing
this so insecure let's sing
[Music]
this
no oh my god dude you spin me right
round Jesus right round like a record
Jesus round that's what he
did adding the words at the wrong time
did you work on this all you had to do
was replace some of the [__] replace
record with Jesus don't say Jesus and
record unbelievable this guy
dude what's the [__]
song
um the Smashmouth I don't know [__]
also this song dude this song of all the
songs you spin me right round Jesus
right round like Jesus
sing
[Music]
it you sp me right Jesus right like a
Jesus little bit
louder oh my god dude sang little bit
louder absolutely took Liberties little
bit
louder dude that's amaz this guy is
[__] amazing he's invited to my
[__] house you are invite Rick Peno
that's the guy's name you're invited to
my house dude oh my god dude no doubt
this guy for real fxck
hookers there's just no question there's
no
question so many Liberties
[Music]
dude the Mortal Kombat
song finish him finish Jesus
[Music]
him
baptize
him [__] yeah dude [__] yeah dude so
closeted that guy for
[Music]
real wow dude how did that part happen I
skipped
ahead break it
down grab your partner doy do don't be
shy just let it go grab your partner doy
do we're having a holy ghost hold down
grab your partner doy do oh wow he's
rocking grab your partner doy down we
having a holy ghost hold
down wow
dude back Streets back Jesus all
right
everybody Jesus yeah Rock Jesus
body
yeah Jesus
everybody back Jesus Streets back
[Music]
tonight wow that guy's killing every
he's doing so many
notes
[Music]
what's this
one and back to
Jesus I mean dude so many songs scream
everybody you know it's so annoying this
guy's just screaming everybody a little
bit
louder honestly this is insane that this
guy did this but he's invited to my
house free open invitation come on over
Rick Peno let's look up Rick Peno Rick
let's look up Rick Peno Grio right now
dude Rick Peno Grio Rick
Pino here we
go oh he's got long hair now this guy
rocks is he religious
dude he did something that he's not
religious
anymore got to has to be is Rick Pino
still
religious oh no he still is huh
conversation of worship Rick penino
leads 12 oh he's a worship
coach hey friends what's up it's Rick
penino here I'm excited to share this
broadcast with you to give you a little
bit of context so it's been all the the
virus and the quarantine broken out to
gather people from our movement for
those who don't know my wife and I we
founded a worship and missions movement
about six years ago called okay I love
this guy seems like the nicest guy in
the [__] world in all
honesty and now I feel bad that I made
fun of him um but you spin me right
around you don't have to make the jokes
dude this [__] is real it's it already
happens